ben bernanke sir up to eight years from
2006 as chairman of the Federal Reserve
he said monetary policy during the worst
of the Great Recession
he chronicles the economic crisis and
it's aftermath and his memoir the
courage to act the book is out in
paperback today with an update featuring
his reaction to the 2016 election he
left the Fed three years ago and is now
a distinguished fellow in residence at
the Brookings Institution good morning
sir good morning to listen to the Trump
administration a lot of that tax reform
a lot of their budgeting a lot of that
economic future is based on economic
growth and they say that they will get a
three point to economic growth annual
growth rate is that achievable and
sustainable well first we want to do
whatever we can to increase growth
because growth has not been enough but
there are a lot of headwinds we've got
pretty slow growth in our labor force
we've got pretty slow growth and
productivity so in order to get growth
up we're going to have to make move a
lot it's going to have to go a lot so I
have a bull and sustainable it's
probably not no not not unless we get
kind of lucky honestly but certainly we
want to do what we can to to improve our
pace of growth you write that that
Donald Trump shocked the world those are
your words by defeating Hillary Clinton
with his dystopian assessment of the US
economy what was dystopian about it well
in some ways it was odd because in many
ways the US economy is doing pretty well
I mean we've created 16 million jobs
since 2009 the unemployment rate is went
from 10 percent down to four and a half
percent housing markets coming back lots
of things are positive and yet mr. Trump
won the election by talking about 42%
unemployment and things like that so it
wasn't accurate there's not 42%
unemployment but but he was right that
there are some people who are being left
behind yeah I mean you write about that
you talk about some consequential
negative longer-term trends the United
States slow productivity you just said
it but also increasing income and wealth
equality and specifically the employment
of men in this country right so for
example as you say inequality since the
last 30 35 years the income
distributions been spreading out more
people at the top fewer people in the
middle more at the bottom
you mentioned participation which means
that
got a lot of young men between ages 25
54 in the past they would have been
working at a regular job but today about
12% of those men are not working or even
looking for work so those kinds of
trends which are very long-standing and
not recent have left behind a lot of
people and that's the kind of concern
that Donald Trump tapped into will you
write this to his ideological influence
are diverse and sometimes contradictory
he just recently released his his tax
reform plan are you encouraged by what
you see well I'm the ideological
influences it's a complicated political
situation because he's got on one hand
traditional Republicans who are anti
deficit pro-free trade for example then
he got populist who are for example
against free trade so he's got these
different you know trains of thought
going on at the same time yeah yeah are
you encouraged by what you see well it's
pretty early and I wrote in my book that
I thought that the you know the markets
got really excited after the election
expecting rapid changes in fiscal policy
regulations so on and I wrote in my book
that I thought because of these
different political influences and the
fact that even within the Republican
Party there was a lot of disagreement I
argued it would take a long time for
this stuff to be put in place so I think
it's quite early yet there's not a whole
lot in place at this point in terms of
regulation we did away with
glass-steagall would it be good to to
bring glass-steagall back in terms of
separating commercial banking from other
banks oh so glass-steagall was a law
that separated commercial banks ordinary
lending banks from investment banks
which are invest in markets and so on
it's become kind of a symbol of the
financial crisis but I don't think it
really had much to do with the crisis
because you had regular commercial banks
getting into trouble making bad loans
and he had investment banks getting into
trouble in the markets putting them
together taking them apart didn't make
that much difference the best thing to
do to deal with income inequality that
you spoke to and the plight of the
middle class is it simply economic
growth economic growth important but
since it doesn't lift all of boats
equally that's not enough what we're
missing in the country is enough upward
mobility so if you are born in the
bottom quarter of the income
distribution if you are a lower
working-class person or you have single
family single parent family those kinds
of problems
it's much harder for you to get up to
the professional upper levels of our of
our society so what we need is a whole
raft of things including you know pre-k
intervention better schooling or
apprenticeship s--
stronger college programs a whole
variety of things to get people better
trained give them a chance to make it up
into the upper ocean you and I spoke
when you're when your book first came
out and I really I really like this
afterward I think it explains so so much
and one of the things you talk about too
Trump has the president has promised to
bring back manufacturing and mining jobs
to make America great is that realistic
to try and bring back those jobs no it's
not realistic because for example coal
mining there's a lot of reasons why coal
mining is declining we have cheap
natural gas many other things going on
so it's better instead of trying to go
back to the past and reproduce 1960s
assembly lines be much better to go to
the industries of the future but in
services technology finance the whole
range of things that we do do well yeah
how that change is really what's
upsetting the electorate this change of
how this economy has today yeah people
people miss what they had but you have
to look forward and look for the
opportunities in the future thanks miss
Jim yeah thank you very much thanks for
having us today